russia's war on ukraine isn't just being
fought by the armies of the two
countries
tens of thousands of foreigners are
joining both sides
will they face consequences under
international law and how will they
affect the conflict
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum russia and ukraine have
mobilized hundreds of thousands of
soldiers to fight the war and both
countries have made calls for foreigners
to join their side volunteers are
already making their way to the front
lines an al jazeera correspondent met
these men from sweden and switzerland on
the train from poland to ukraine one
said he faces three years in jail when
he returns home but insisted the
sacrifice is worth it
ukraine says up to 20 000 volunteers
from 52 countries have signed up to join
an international legion
if this person fits
requirement
we give the person contact in ukraine
and person goes to ukraine
and then signs uh contract with armed
forces of ukraine so the there is not
mercenaries who are coming to end money
no not at all this is a good people of
goodwill
who are coming to assist ukraine to
fight for freedom
on the russian side president vladimir
putin has approved allowing foreign
fighters the defense minister says 16
000 volunteers from the middle east are
ready to join the u.s believes moscow is
recruiting in syria where russia has
been helping government forces since
2015. but the kremlin says those from
the west who fight on ukraine's side
will be considered mercenaries with no
protection under the geneva convention
as to recruiting mercenaries all over
the world and sending them to ukraine we
can see that they the western sponsors
of ukraine they're not hiding it they're
doing it openly neglecting every norm of
international law
therefore if you see that there are
people willing to go there and help the
people of tombas as volunteers
especially free of charge well we should
grant their wish and help them reach the
combat zone
who came up with the idea of throwing
mercenaries against our people thugs
from syria from the country that was
destroyed in the same way as the
invaders are destroying us now
all right let's take a look at the role
of foreign fighters in conflicts
the war in syria had one of the largest
mobilization of foreigners thousands of
them came from western europe to fight
after the rise of isil in 2014 the u.n
security council adopted resolutions to
prevent the recruitment and travel of
foreign fighters
volunteers for ukraine have been signing
up at a faster rate than even in 2014 in
syria and iraq
some countries like belgium have tried
to discourage their citizens from going
while others like latvia have approved a
bill for people to take up arms for
ukraine
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in moscow pavel felgenhauer
defense and military analyst in
providence rhode island in the u.s
anthony dworkin senior policy fellow at
the european council on foreign
relations and in doha omar ashore
founding chair of the doha institute's
critical security studies program a warm
welcome to you all and thanks so much
for joining us today on inside story
omar let me start with you today all
these foreign fighters that are joining
the conflict in ukraine on both sides
what kind of an impact is that going to
have
well er
historically we know that it has a
an impact uh some benefits and uh and
maybe a lot of costs so on the benefit
side
they depending on the the type they have
a military impact
uh from a word from the spanish civil
war when you have the international
brigade
was
quantity means quality
because of their numbers the sheer
numbers even though poor training and
less expertise
they managed to stop the franco's army
from taking madrid and uh madrid didn't
really fall except
except after the collapse of the war
after the collapse of the republic and
the end of the war
um
so there's some military benefits they
increase the manpower of whichever side
they they
go to
they help with logistics and supplies
some may bring military expertise
depending if they were regulars or
irregulars so they fought before
and then
let's say an insurgency or or an
irregular warfare situation or if they
have formal military training meaning
that they were part of an official
armed institute um
and uh also they
uh help with the morale boost
uh unit cohesion if especially the
ideologues the hardcores um they they
help a lot with the unit cohesion we
know that and
sometimes also they
give international legitimacy
good with further recruitment of other
foreign volunteers
and it depends on on uh the
the
the the narrative that the the the
uh the the that is upheld
uh they help with uh further
uh let's say internationalization of the
cause we're getting further legitimacy
of the cause that's on one side but the
costs of course we know that any
mobilization and any demobilization uh
has uh a lot of costs
uh also the uh
always the opposing side uses or ab uses
uh so let's say if there are volunteers
actual volunteers who are committed to
the cause of defending ukraine let's say
the other side russia in this case will
be saying that these are not volunteers
these are mercenaries
and if they are coming there to defend
the democracy they will be accused of
being extremists and so on and the other
way around of course the other side has
also i'm not saying that there are no
ideologues there are no people with like
some uh
let's say extremist ideologies uh
involved but uh but
they are very very different uh types of
uh reasons people volunteer
there are also mercenaries meaning that
they're actually paid to fight
so those also exist
but somehow volunteer and mercenary they
get brushed sometimes with the same
brush
let me let me
let me let me get back to you on that
point about mercenaries in just a couple
of minutes pavel let me go to you how
important is it for president putin at
this particular time whether
symbolically or logistically how
important is it for him to have foreign
fighters involved
well first of all we should understand
that there are no foreign fighters there
in fact on the front line not on the
russian side and a very very small
number
on the ukrainian side so we're talking
about um
a future kind of situation more than one
that's already there uh president uh
putin
the russian defense minister sergey
shougu publicly told the president that
there are lots of volunteers in syria
with uh combat experience apparently who
can want to want to join the fight and
the donbass and the president okay that
they don't understand understand they
didn't come there yet
it's important for russia of course it's
important symbolically that the russian
cause
is good of course and it's going to be
joined by foreigners and the secondary
the russians actually have a very
serious manpower issue with their
military effort in ukraine the regular
russian army is more or less all in not
all of course it has but it can't move
all its troops i mean not from the kuril
islands not from kaliningrad and so on
there are places where you have to keep
garrisons anyways and they don't have
much trained reserves so
combat veterans from syria who had
actually fought with the russians and
know the russians they've been kind of
in daryl
and then aleppo and gupta together so if
they kind of join the fight well that
would help at least partially in the
problem with reserves uh that right now
the russian military has anthony i saw
you nodding um to some of what pablo was
saying this i'm gonna let you jump in
but i also wanted to ask you
what are some of the legal ramifications
when it comes to foreign fighters
volunteering for a conflict such as this
one
there's a big difference
between
foreign fighters who are
kind of incorporated into the armed
forces of one of the
parties to the conflict whether it's
ukraine or russia
that is a perfectly established um
procedure with
historical precedence um as omar
mentioned the spanish civil war
obviously being
a primary one
and
under the the rules of war it's
perfectly accepted that you can bring
people in
but the question is are they part of the
regular
armed forces or are they sort of
um freelancers who are kind of appearing
on the battlefield uh really
of their own volition without
formally being incorporated into the
armed forces and that makes a certain
difference because if they are part of
the armed forces then they
enjoy what's
known as the privilege of the combatant
in other words if they're captured
they haven't committed any crime they
have to be treated as prisoners of war
um this is all assuming that they fight
in a lawful way but their presence on
the battlefield is accepted if they are
just kind of freelancers or
war tourists who are turning up with a
gun
then they're in a different position
because they're still counted as
civilians but they're civilians who are
fighting and so potentially they could
be
prosecuted under the law of the opposing
country for acts of violence anthony if
i could just sorry to interrupt if i
could just also ask you though do you do
you believe that there's going to be
enough concern
about
what types of fighters are out there by
governments that they would initiate
releasing guidelines for their citizens
to follow in the event that they want to
volunteer in ukraine
it's been if looking at the how western
governments have dealt with this issue
has been interesting and there have been
some quite
and
sponsors so
obviously
the governments in europe the united
states are
very committed to supplying assistance
to ukraine um
short stopping short of joining
the conflict themselves um
and some of them the british foreign
secretary in particular liz trust went
so far as to suggest that it would be a
good thing for british citizens to go
and fight
but the british defense secretary really
kind of wrote back on that comment and
i think he has the better case because
encouraging your citizens
uh who may or may not have any uh
military training
um
to
simply go abroad into a obviously very
dangerous
zone um
there are a lot of risks to that
obviously the government can't protect
them
the motivations why people may be there
could be quite mixed um
you know there are concerns obviously
about some of them um when they come
back so
it's a it's a complicated and
delicate question i think um you know
people who have extensive military
experience who've served in armed forces
um perhaps they would be able to make
that adjustment
there's also a question about how these
people would fight when they're there do
they have the kind of discipline and
training to fight in accordance with the
laws of war so there are a lot of
concerns involved omar you were talking
before about the different types of
fighters that you were talking
specifically about mercenaries and i'm
curious to get your opinion about if
governments are concerned about what may
happen to some of these fighters once
they actually return to their home
countries
there is uh usually that concern uh but
actually the mercedes when it comes to
that concern it's uh they're not the
major concern because they're paid to
fight if you don't pay them they won't
fight basically
uh um so but others um
there may be some concerns with uh
you know the volunteers for example that
once uh
in syria and got particular type of
training that could be used in
urban terror
building of iads
sniping in urban areas and so on so
forth and they
because of the ideology because of the
world view
their perception was that they may cause
a threat when they demobilize and return
back to home countries especially if
they are affiliated with
organizations such as isis and
others
in the case of ukraine clearly it's a
bit different
so
the main i guess the main concern that
the security services would not western
security services would not come out and
say this publicly because they they need
to be ideologically politically correct
and so on but there's a concern with the
ideology on one end
and there's a concern
with the type of training that these
volunteers will get
and of course there is a concern for why
did they go to the war and which
organization they are affiliated with
when they go to the the conflict area
uh some of this the do not really exist
in ukraine in the ukrainian conflict and
initially did not uh exist
in the libyan conflict uh remember there
were several volunteers who went also to
libya uh to fight against gaddafi regime
back in the libyan revolution 2011 and
there was there was limited there was
let's say less concern than when the
case uh uh escalated in syria in 2013
and 2014 and the rise of isis and so on
so forth um so these are some
differences but also i want to say that
the foreign involvement i may i agree
with everything that was said but that i
may differ a bit on the involvement of
foreigners because from the very
beginning from 2014
uh there were foreign fighters for very
different reasons on both sides uh in
the ukrainian case and uh
you know the the bianca battalions
mainly from moldovans from transnisteria
some of the the serbian hussar regiment
for
serbian volunteers that's that's
fighting on the side of russia and some
uh
remnants of
some battalions that fought for the
russians in chechnya vostok battalion is
one of them uh although they they
somehow were incorporated loosely within
the
um within the uh luhansk and donetsk and
the backers back in 2014 but they showed
up in crimea they were very clean in
2014 they were in crimea
and uh with videos and pictures so so
they were there these are uh uh
ethnically chechens
uh omar i'm sorry i'm sorry to interrupt
the other side as well omar i'm sorry to
interrupt you we are starting to run out
of time pavel let me let me ask you this
um when russian president putin and when
the russian defense minister make the
announcement that
there are foreign fighters who would
volunteer to go to dumbass
is this a decision that was made
in order to counter what ukraine is
doing when it comes to setting up an
international legion or was this done
because there is worry
that um russians would be unhappy
if more russian forces would be called
up to go into ukraine
well yes i say the russian uh
political military readership have a
problem with reserves if this war begins
to drag on and develop into a kind of
war of attrition there will be serious
problems with uh replacing manpower and
general the
attrition is not really what russia is
that much ready for
and announcing uh mobilization and
actually in the donbass in these uh so
self-requiring republics which are now
recognized by russia there is a total
mobilization of the male population
but in russia there is not
putin went public saying there will be
no reservists and no conscripts on the
front line only volunteers
because he knows that politically that
would be not very well
badly received by the russian public as
long as it's of all volunteer force or
semi-volunteer fighting there that's
more politically acceptable
so they would need of course volunteers
and russians actually are not flocking
to volunteer to go to work
very much i mean to
the ukraine very much
and that's a bit of a problem on the
other side the ukrainians don't seem to
have a manpower issue and i don't know
will they form a foreign region or not
but they have a problem with specialists
and the commanders as they are expanding
their military very much right now
there's lots of volunteers there are
lots of reservists some of them with
military expertise i mean with some
experience fighting in the donbass but
with different weapons now there's
western weapons they need specialists
and western weapons maybe even western
colonels majors generals that would be
advisors or actually commanders of new
reformed units as the ukrainian war
effort expands
so these are different things russians
don't want uh to have you know syrian
generals fighting commanding their
troops in the donbass but they need
manpower the ukrainians need not
manpower but they need expertise and
commanders maybe pavel you also
mentioned earlier that from your
perspective these fighters wouldn't be
ready any time soon when do you think
that they might be ready
well i mean it's there's a logistical
problem to bring them from syria uh
especially with the russian airplanes
right now being arrested and not allowed
to move fly out of russia
again you have to kind of well
filter out who's in syria who who these
people are of course the russians are
already there in syria they have their
connections there maybe that will be a
bit easier to bring those who want to
really know how to fight and not those
who
just simply want to find a way to get a
russian or actually at the nets passport
and then try to infiltrate europe and
they're not really interested in really
fighting the ukrainian armed forces so
that will take time to form kind of any
kind of
large numbers
on the ukrainian side also the numbers
are not very high right now but
apparently there's a lot of people ready
to volunteer but again they're going to
have a problem to discriminate who's
there as a tourist and who's really
ready to fight and actually knows how to
do it and will add
to the ukrainian effort and not detract
from it
anthony from your perspective um
whenever it is that
more
foreign fighters or volunteers are
actually on the ground in parts of
ukraine
do you believe that these fighters could
face severe consequences under
international law
it depends what happens to them and it
depends how they fight i mean clearly if
these foreign fighters are captured by
russian forces
there are i guess two questions number
one is the question of what should
happen to them um and they could be
prosecuted
if they're not part of a formal military
brigade so
um but as i understand it there is at
least an effort to incorporate them into
a brigade in which case they should
receive treatment as prisoners of war um
then of course there is sometimes a kind
of special appropriate that can attach
to
people who are seen to be
um
you know from outside maybe
um illegitimate they don't belong there
um they're particularly resented you
know so i think they are potentially um
putting themselves at some risk but it's
not they're not
actually committing a crime by going and
if they fight in a lawful way
then
you know there is no problem um
under the law now of course there is a
question about whether the countries
that they come from
might want to prosecute them when they
come back
um and they're in the case of
the uk for instance there is a kind of
archaic law
um in the british statute book that says
fighting against the country that
britain is not formally at war with is a
crime but that
is kind of uh
you know not observed and that was never
used to prosecute people in the spanish
civil war and i don't think it would be
in this case
so really um the people who are
prosecuted are the people who fight for
organizations that their countries deem
as terrorists
and
i mean as as we know there are some
extremist elements uh on the ukrainian
side but
i think the prevalent view would be that
most people fighting in ukraine now are
not fighting for a cause that western
governments would deem as terrorists and
therefore i think we would see a
different approach anthony for the
fighters who are coming from nato
countries how much does that complicate
the situation on the ground and also let
me ask you um
for countries who have fighters on the
ground in ukraine if those fighters were
to get kidnapped or killed or injured
is there a fear in those countries that
there would be domestic pressure for
those countries to then somehow
intervene
in the war
right i think the
essential point here is that western
countries are trying to do essentially
everything that they can up to the
threshold of directly
joining the armed conflict on the side
of ukraine so um and you can see that
they're trying quite carefully just to
stop short of that threshold so for
instance the debate that took place
about sending um war planes uh from nato
war planes either from poland or via the
us
um i think illustrated that because
there was the sense that if um
ukrainian pilots were allowed to fly
planes from western countries into the
battle space that that would count as uh
you know the essentially they would be
launching attacks from
poland or germany or wherever and i
think he would see the same thing with
respect to the volunteers you know there
would be an absolute prohibition on any
serving members of military forces
in western countries going in any kind
of official capacity or even
um i think there would be a lot of
concern even if they were going in an
unofficial capacity um
to
you know in a context where it could be
perceived as
um right nato forces fighting on behalf
of ukraine but people who have military
experience who've left their forces um
that i think would be seen in a
different way and i think it would
essentially be understood that they were
going at their own risk right um i don't
think that even if they were killed that
that would significantly change the
debate in western countries about
participation all right well we have run
out of time so we're going to have to
leave the conversation there thank you
so much to all of our guests pablo
felgenhauer anthony dworkin and omar
ashore
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad zhum and the whole team here
bye for now
[Music]
you